on the mound for the red sox with a
record of bowen 2
and a 4.01 era left-hander
martine perez jose glacier's 288 couple
of home runs
there's a hard ground ball to shore
bogarts has it fires to second for the
force that retires the side and glaciers
out on one pitch and the red sox
survived three base runners in the first
inning and
the angels do not score on the mount for
the halos with the record of owen four
and a 5.03 era
is right-hander dylan bundy
i think one hit will get verdugo going
change his outlook a little bit
he's such an emotional player in his
career he's 25 and 13 when he doesn't
give up a homer there's a drive to right
field this is high and deep back goes
ward looking up and there's a home run
alex verdugo against the wind with a
towering shot above the red sox bullpen
into the bleachers one-nothing red sox
his fifth homer is 17th rbi so
he breaks out of the old for 14 in style
hello happy birthday vasquez will be the
next batter
here's the pitch and this one it's
chopped on the left side should be the
inning rindone has it throws to first
handled by gosling a little bit of a low
throw but the inning ends on the
5-3 ground out gosling at first base
today
here's the pitch and a strike over the
inside corner beautifully located
fastball at 93 and gosselin took it with
a bat on his shoulder
one down for justin upton hitting at
202. he's homered seven times and is
driven in 14.
one two pitch is over the outside edge
strike three call
often looks down at the plate but he
flips the bat and goes back to the
dugout very slowly
did award he walked to begin the ball
game in the first inning against martin
perez
pitch is called strike three on the
inside corner good fastball and martine
perez is mowing him down
third strikeout here comes otani three
balls two strikes the pitch swing and a
miss he struck
him out a high fastball ohtani is gone
marwan gonzalez is over one
here's the next pitch and that is right
in there for a called third strike
so outlooking is gonzales dalbeck hit
one
forever last night can he do it again
here
bogart's at second devers at first
here's the pitch
curveball hit high into left field way
back on it after a wall is upton
with his back to the wall up and leaps
he can't get it
bogarts has scored devers is around
third he is in there
bobby dulbeck a two-run monster double
and it's three nothing red sox
here's francie cordero oh and one to
cordero
the pitch swinging a shot off the glove
of the first baseman gosselin
dulbeck comes to third he is waved home
he will score
cordero ahead first dive into second a
rocket to right field in france she has
a double
that makes it four nothing red sox
and that'll send up marwan gonzalez
who's flight out and struck out
here's the next delivery this is popped
in the air out towards mike trout not
very deep at all comes over makes the
catch and the inning comes to an end but
the red sox add on here in the inning
they score three times they'll leave a
runner on and the angels have some
catching up to do as we head to the
fifth it's four nothing boston
sanders walked and then flicked the low
outside the
curve ball into left field down the line
for a double
now he sets in the 2-2 swing there's a
drive to left field this is
long gone out of the ballpark completely
on the lansdowne street three run homer
xander bogarts his ninth
and the red sox now lead it seven to
nothing oh was that crushed the high
line driver was still
rising when it cleared the billboard out
there and left
and went out toward the hotel
commonwealth
what a blast by xander bogarts and
christian vasquez now yeah definitely
the command for bundy
just not quite there first inning you
could see he was off but was able to
work his way through it
settled into his game the next couple of
innings
and then the red sox scoring four couple
three times
in that fourth inning and
all that damage comes with two outs
wasn't able to get out of that
here's the next pitch lifted in the air
into right center field that ball's hit
well
and running it down out on the warning
track is mike trout the runner at first
was already at second he has to
head back to the bag devers nice running
catch out there by
trout in right center that was right in
front of the
red sox bullpen and trout made the grab
on the track
great jump by trout to catch this ball
this left the bat i thought it was
either going to be gone or
certainly into the gap mike trout
is already fifth all-time on the angels
career hit list
14 18 for him
trout that is the one two is spoiled
into the seats right behind dome plate
somebody made a play
let's see what we got here oh whoa
and that'll bring up franchi cordero a
lot of extra base hits
today francie rips another one inside
the first base bag that carrum's off the
tarp
dalbeck is going to score francie turns
heads to second
he slides in safely consecutive
rbi doubles for franchi cordero
and it's eight nothing boston and now jd
martinez will be the next batter
and it looks like the angels are
probably going to
face a reliever the red sox have action
in their bullpen
pitch on its way this is lifted high in
the air into right center and
playable mike trout will cut right in
front of the
right fielder taylor ward there make the
catch on that one and the
inning comes to an end it ends on a fly
out to the angel center fielder
one out and here comes devers the one oh
to rafi swinging in a high fly ball
to right field back on a ward at the
wall goodbye
rafi launches one over the red sox
bullpen
his tenth home run and it's nine
nothing red sox third homer hit by the
sox today
and it's a party at fenway so two down
two on then here's iglesias who's over
three
the pitch swinging a weak ground ball
stabbed by the pitcher right of the
monitor high hop underhand flip to first
retires the side so
darwin's in survives two walks in a wild
pitch we go to the bottom of the eighth
marwin today over four
1-1 pitch swinging a hard grounder foul
down the third base line nice pick by
the ball girl there
and another souvenir
the runner at first with two down for
david fletcher
austin bryce set the deal here it comes
and a ground ball bounce to first easy
hop for dahlbach five steps to the bag
and that's the ball game the red sox
blank
the los angeles angels the final boston
nine
and the angels nothing the red sox go to
nine over 500 at 25
and 16 the angels drop six under